suzune ayo cuban slang for the
fluttering sound a hummingbird makes and
the name of a Cuban Twitter like social
media platform that was exposed earlier
this year as being a project sponsored
by none other than the United States of
America specifically USAID an agency
that usually runs international
humanitarian projects zooms an ale
however was part of USAID so called
pro-democracy activities and was meant
to encourage young Cubans to revolt
programmers designs and nao to work
around strict government internet
controls by using text messages and the
40,000 Cubans who started signing up for
the service in 2010 had no idea that
Uncle Sam was behind it all they also
had no idea their info was being stored
for future political use we can't talk
about at this time
needless to say Cuba was not happy with
the news
as one official put it it shows once
again that the United States has not
renounced its plans of subversion
against Cuba but wait that's not all
The Associated Press recently revealed
yet another secret program that sent
almost a dozen young Latin Americans to
the island to try and get young Cubans
to become anti-government activists for
two years the spy kids lived in Cuba
under the guise of tourists and even
used the cover of an HIV prevention
workshop to try and recruit dissidents
classy the young operatives were hardly
given any training and to top it off
they were paid slave wages that would
make James Bond join the KGB back to
zooms and ale the White House says it
was totally transparent and yet it was
financed through a foreign bank and in a
memo a contractor specifically reassured
that quote there will be absolutely no
mention of United States government
involvement right senator Patrick Leahy
who helps oversee USAID s budget says
Congress wasn't hip to the plan
legislation doesn't say anything about
setting up a cockamamie idea in Cuba
with Twitter account and then in 2012
just as mysteriously as it had arrived
dooms nao is gone following the strange
foreign tourists who had flown the coop
months before leaving many Cubans to
wonder episome